every member of the Spelman family is
born with a twin yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
explaining all the chilling clues that
Sabrina may well have a twin who hasn't
been revealed yet
keep watching to the end to find out who
its most likely to be spoilers ahead so
take care if you're not all caught up
otherwise tap here to watch my spoiler
free review the origins of the twin
theory begin right in the very first
episode of chilling adventures in the
scene where Sabrina is taking a bath and
suddenly has a vision which transports
her into the woods she sees her parents
holding a crying baby and as she follows
them she discovers two babies she lifts
up the blanket covering them and
discovers one of the babies has cloven
hooves rather than human feet like the
other child the vision disappears but it
leaves us with a lingering thought as to
what it really means on one level this
vision of two babies is symbolic of
Sabrina's dual nature she's half witch
and half mortal it also represents the
decision that Sabrina wrestles were
throughout the first season the
cloven-hoofed baby on the Left
represents her pledging allegiance to
the Dark Lord and the human baby on the
right symbolizes the mortal world
Sabrina is trying to avoid leaving
behind there's also some foreshadowing
of father Blackwood's twins in the scene
I'll talk more about that later but in a
show like chilling adventures there are
often multiple layers of meaning to
important scenes like this one and fans
of the old school Sabrina the Teenage
Witch sitcom will remember the line that
every member of the Spellman family is
born with a twin curiously the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina has already been
exploring the idea of secret twins in
its first season in the season 1 finale
Zelda steals away Blackwood's firstborn
daughter to raise with Hilda leaving the
high priests with what he thinks is an
only son and a were that little Judas
actually has a twin sister in episode 5
dreams in a which housed the Spellman's
end up being tortured by the sleep demon
batty bat and during Hilda's nightmare
principal Hawthorne reveals it unknown
to most people except his mother he had
a twin brother who he absorbed while in
the womb during that same nightmare
Hilda has a vision that she in
Zelda have been sewn together and become
inseparable like conjoined twins indeed
it's interesting that the show's
production designer Lisa Soper told
website black girl nerds that she thinks
of Hilda and Zelda as conjoined twins in
fact that's why she created that single
chair the sisters share in their office
obviously these last two examples in
episode 5 of visions and demonstrate
Hilda's fear of a never-ending
codependence with her sister but they
also show that chilling adventures is
rather interested in the idea of twins
and the storytelling opportunities they
afford and Zelda taking away Lady
Blackwood's daughter to raise and secret
brings up an interesting theory that
Zelda and Hilda already did this with
another baby we can raise her we've
touched before we'll keep it a secret
you and I together sisters most of us
probably assumed Zelda was referring to
how she and Hilda Rae Sabrina after her
parents died but what if she really
means the two aunts he secretly raised
the other baby that Sabrina saw in her
vision fans of the old-school Sabrina
show have seen something like this
before in the 90s sitcom Sabrina meets
her identical twin Katrina the end of
the third season and it becomes a
humorous plot point when they have to
undergo a test to find out which sibling
is the evil one
the test of course reveals Sabrina's
sister Katrina as the evil sibling and
Katrina is then sent to live in the twin
cities in a place known as the other
realm in that show the other realm is a
separate dimension accessed via a portal
and chilling adventures has already
shown as a similar albeit darker
alternate dimension limbo access to
limbo is also through a portal and in
the scenes we've seen so far we've also
heard the sound of babies crying there
we know from Sabrina's mother Diana that
unbaptized babies are sent to limbo
so is it possible that Sabrina's
potential sibling is stuck in limbo
similar to how Sabrina's twin Katrina
was stuck in the other realm in the
teenage witch show there's another
possible twin clue in what Sabrina's
mother says to her in limbo they took
her she took my baby after the baptism
who did
are you okay what Diana says to Sabrina
could mean a couple of things it could
suggest that Sabrina was taken away from
her mother after her Christian baptism
and then promised to the Dark Lord
Zelda witness the pledge that Sabrina's
father made to the Dark Lord but she
appeared to be totally unaware of
Sabrina's Christian baptism so unless
Zelda is hiding something about this it
could be that diana is referring to
someone else could it be then that Diana
had a second child perhaps a twin of
Sabrina and that baby was taken away
from her so who are the likely
candidates for Sabrina's secret twin one
possibility is Connor Kemper the young
warlock who arrived at the Spellman
mortuary in the first episode his death
is still a mystery at the end of season
one and I'm assuming it's something that
will be tackled in the second season
someone who could be an especially
interesting reveal of Sabrina's twin is
Nick scratch Nick seems to be a genuine
friend of Sabrina's and he supported her
when she objected to the feast of feasts
however he could be hiding a darker side
which would play nicely into the idea of
an evil twin the clue to his darker
nature may well be hiding in plain sight
and it's actually his name Nick scratch
old Nick and old scratch are both
nicknames for the devil so could he be
the dark twin or even the devil himself
in disguise we know Nick is into Sabrina
and with Sabrina looking like she's
going a bit wicked at the end of the
season there's a hint she could hook up
with him in season two before they
realize they're related if indeed they
are so he might well be looking at a
Luke and Leia Skywalker or Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen situation other
possibilities the Sabrina's twin could
be the weird sister Dorcas who have been
told as an orphan or perhaps a new
character will meet in season two or
maybe somebody who's stuck in limbo or
possibly even a character from Riverdale
now do you think season 2 of chilling
adventures will reveal a twin for
Sabrina I've added a poll where you can
vote just tap in the top right of this
video and after you've cost you vote
you'll be able to see the results tap
left to watch my full breakdown of the
first season of Sabrina plus some other
theories for season two or tap right for
the top ten differences between the new
Sabrina and her 90s sitcom if you
enjoyed this remember to subscribe and
leave a thumbs up for more videos like
this
thanks for watching and see you next
time you PKA movie lovers